christelle bonjour alors des entretiens
entre le ministre de l'intérieur et les
syndicats de police pour désamorcer la
colère des policiers c'est bien cela
oui christophe castaner qui est
confronté à la colère des policiers qui
tentent aujourd'hui encore 2 rgs ravir
l'everest de la confiance pour reprendre
l'expression du secrétaire général du
syndicat unité sgp police deuxième
journée vous l'avez dit de rencontre
aujourd'hui entre elles et syndicats de
police et le ministre de l'intérieur ici
à beauvau et il est à la peine en un
christophe castaner les premiers rendez
vous a dit hier n'ont pas suffi à calmer
le jeu entre hal et flic de france et
leur chef les policiers qui se sentent
elle lâché désavoué par christophe
castaner l'objet de leur colère et bien
ce sont là les déclarations du ministre
de l'intérieur en début de semaine et
christophe castaner qui a plaidé pour
une tolérance zéro sur le racisme dans
la police est pour l'interdiction de
certaines à techniques d'interpellation
comme par exemple est la clé
d'étranglement hier soir à lissieu de ca
premier entretien
certains policiers ont exprimé leur
colère dans des rassemblements dans
plusieurs villes de france où ils ont
jeté à leurs menottes à terre et puis
aujourd'hui en fin de matinée à
plusieurs policiers syndiqués ont
organisé une action surprise c'est une
action surprise qui a commencé place de
l'étoile pour s'achever ici à place
beauvau ils ont entonné la marseillaise
et certains policiers à syndiqués ont
réclamé à être reçu par le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron c'est donc dans
ce contexte que sont reçus se tape cet
après-midi par l'ats christophe castaner
les secrétaires généraux d'officiers et
de commissaires patrice ribeiro et david
le bar merci beaucoup estelle pour
toutes ces précisions estelle farges en
direct de la place beauvau fois